welcome to this video playing am
Rainmaker yeah man I am yet but i tend
to use this german way of doing it the
Yemm the Rainmaker yeah this looks wacky
but it's not so bad black is so Miss
placing the the White Knight and its
really really bad only three blacks
night on a six also isn't that brilliant
if it has to go there ultimately but
it's not such a big deal Black has very
good control over you form this is
important yeah I wonder maybe it C is he
going for queen bee three bishop d to
this could be could be an idea mmm high
five you can probably do this and a 5c
five I don't know that should be too bad
oops please not the beep on good thing
that I have smart move off now for
thinking b6 which is a bit
unconventional but I mean winning the
porn is not that brilliant okay maybe
yeah I mean a more or less committed to
that yeah it's more likely that you will
actually grab them what really might be
a problem is there is this after be
takes after after this capture that is
got 94 this is this is looking like a
problem
and that really looks like a problem 97
seems very slow 94 maybe 94 tough and I
don't want to fall even more behind on
the clock yeah i was thinking that I can
really do this and just just play this
position I think I have some
compensation for that point maybe I'm
wrong I mean but I felt that I have some
some play how he just returns it just
returns it
yeah white has the better development so
he probably still is somewhat better
look see one maybe Brooke FC one yeah
cakes and c5 yep Jack I guess I have to
one thing my position really has in its
favor my king is doing something it's
really more active than the g one g one
colleague
I really need to get this rook into the
game okay I was thinking actually King c
6 cm then King be 60 I didn't think
about this move very much but it soft
was good try to just put more pressure
on the porn be four let them know i have
c4 that should be ok unless he has not
xt5 a king six balls a bit over was
brave brave move c 4 95 95 look-see for
check here King d6 rock deform map not
good
I'm really have no move them can go to
be 5 55 to 80 sharp f7 why it's not
working or four
yeah it looks that looks amazingly bad
but maybe it's still somewhat playable
okay eight is that losing oh
that looks so sick that diagonal but I
really didn't have nothing else Bishop a
three-time morning bad guy can actually
look back night a 40 k 5 check oh that's
this old pearl jam song I'm still alive
somehow
that this is really a draw i think
amazing somebody somehow swindled myself
into this opposite color Bishop sending
there are honored I don't think that's
particularly great idea by white trying
to try to play this bra offered gain dry
and it's really dead Wow bra that was
really really bad drawing this feels
like a window almost Jam Chan yeah it
felt didn't feel so bad but I really got
myself into huge trouble yeah the
computer wants to go no he wants to
place your fire and now I King King c6
is just crazy probably computers likes
it actually computer we think I'm better
that's cool I went here before and now
94 no I did not think about this move at
all night he was better for black
and my king is playing but it still
feels very strange mean okay because
this is kind of kind of clear here's
Bishop is this kind of bad this is the
engines main line look you one slide
edge for black I don't know yeah I I
really couldn't see anything here that
and here he can win with this okay okay
why because this and I cannot take
because I hoped you one that's a very
difficult technique for Yuma player in
them in short time control and must be
an avid that it really looked like there
should be a win gentium engine is
unequal again I never looked at 94
really can Jim and here it's the draw it
really is a draw i think it's nothing
much after this if you takes I will put
this on f6 and then shuffle forever that
that's that's dead really yeah that was
very lucky escape okay well thanks for
watching